started out a beautiful day this morning
down here at base camp up above it was
great to hear Peter Whitaker and Eddie
stirs got a nice early start out of camp
one moved up the Western combe to camp
to our advanced base camp and melissa
made her way from base camp up to camp
one today our first climbing team is all
up on the mountain now that's not our
schedule my little group myself and Eric
adoring in Seth waterfall it was always
planned that we'd be on different
schedules we're trying to guide Erica
this is her first time on Mount Everest
we've gotta take it slow we can't take
anything for granted and my guess is
we'll be at Camp one in the next few
days so I'm up here at Camp one to spend
my first night here and sometimes it's
the tortoise and hare game and for me
right now it's a tortoise game I hurt my
ankle on the way in I've just been
taking it easy and resting a little bit
longer and I got the okay from the
doctors down at the clinic at base camp
yesterday to actually move up so I'm
going to spend tonight tomorrow night
here at Camp one and then move up to
camp 2 and just pay attention to how I'm
feeling we're up here in the Western
combe about 20,000 feet but you never
guess it we've got reflective walls all
around us and it's just like an oven in
here probably I don't know mid 60's or
something like that makes it pretty warm
for walking it's a beautiful morning
here in the Western Kuhn working our way
up from camp one to camp 2 which is
super exciting I'm Melissa this morning
left base camps you'll be at Camp one
tonight a denial be at Camp two and Dave
and south will be down at base camp so
we're all over the mountain but we're
all working our way up